[Music]
[Applause]
hey you guys happy sunday
yep
don't let us interrupt
him drinking
i got sodas lined up
got an air got a damn refrigerator up
here now
yeah he's very excited just go get him
soda whenever i want one in a can or a
two liter with ice
yeah you drank almost all of it yeah i
gotta bring some water up here to get
the actual okay look
y'all [ __ ] with me
we're to talk about war of the worlds
the 1950s original
yeah this is the well the first movie
adaptation i remember being in
california's little kid i must have been
six or seven and this [ __ ] came on
television
and it came on in the morning i think it
was like maybe those saturday morning
cartoons everything saturday morning
remember this saturday saturday night
morning [ __ ] monster fest and [ __ ]
yeah they still like monsters i find one
yeah
and this one man riveted me i didn't
know what wore the worlds was i just
turned it on and i was like what the
hell is this
this looks like it might be a monster
movie you know
and then the
damn alien craft hits the big i was like
yeah it's kind of like the blob i
remember thinking that
and uh
i was like man this is going to be
trouble here you know what i mean the
second damn
[ __ ] flying saucers not flat saucers
they they were just kind of those manta
ray looking alien ships came out of the
meteors
and then the old preacher says that's it
i'm gonna put ahead of this [ __ ] the
[ __ ] preacher goes out there he
starts praying and i was like yeah this
will put it into that
and they zap that preacher and i'm like
oh we're [ __ ] now
they're [ __ ] now man these aliens are
zap a preacher that was worse than
zapping a kid or a child back in the
mind of a kid back in those days
like damn he killed the preacher we're
[ __ ]
and then you know the martians
destroying everything and
then the damn they then eventually you
get to see a martian it touches that
girl touches the girl
they got this little weird yeah fingery
technically yeah happening and 50s 1950s
jeff goldberg [ __ ] 1950s jeff gold
yeah 19 that's what he's like 1950s jess
jeff goldblum [ __ ] killed the alien
well heard it and it ran off blood i got
blood remember ah and then the girl
screams and [ __ ]
this is just a classic flick me and
jenny watched it the other day
when was it two days ago
uh
significantly longer than that i think
it might have been last thursday or
something like that they're showing a
touched up version of it
on amazon prime for free this [ __ ] was
badass it holds up it holds up
it's a movie of its time really nice it
was ahead of his time
yeah interestingly well see okay when
this first came out back in 1953 for
christ's sake which was like a really
long time ago
it was in technicolor right color yeah
uh well you know technicolor which is a
different process yeah i don't have it
anymore um you know so i think that it
used like three films or three strips or
something like that so it was shot like
that
um but later on when they transferred
the film to uh eastman color film which
was cheaper
uh you could see
like all the wires and stuff that were
holding up the spacecraft yeah you
couldn't see them in the original
version because the technicolor was
better like the process was better but
when they transported a cheaper stock
you did so i feel like for a long time
like after people saw it in the theater
in the 50s and then subsequently when it
played on tv or you know you know later
on when they put it out on video or
whatever i think everybody thought that
the special effects were kind of shitty
in this because like oh you can see the
string but originally you couldn't it
was just uh had to do with the way that
it was transferred like to a different
film stock because this actually won
a special effects oscar in 1953. now i
think
that this was maybe the only like it got
a special oscar because i don't think
they had a category for it i don't even
think there were any other nominees
but yeah but they wanted to give this
one award just because the special
effects were so good and they really are
like a lot of it is
miniature work
matte paintings the matte paintings are
really nice i actually really really
like the way they did
the spacecraft it doesn't look anything
like what h.g wells described no it
looks better in the book but yeah yeah
i'm kind of i like vibed with with the
way that uh well and even when they show
the aliens they don't look exactly like
he described the aliens in the book
either they booked it like an octopus
basically kind of octopus the size of a
bear their teeth yeah and they were kind
of like they were just kind of just
heads and they had like little tentacles
like tentacles and like a little like v
mouth like with a little fang in it or
something like that yeah they were it's
been a lot of killing people and
taking them taking their bloods out and
injected it into their own veins and
they were still mean but they were
running around a big mechanical tripod
so it looked like a damn water tower
walking around
but this movie rebooted it they looked
like a
like a manta ray with a damn
head where's that electric eye that came
out of the top of it yeah it was being
supported by
any gravity beams which you could see
him in this version
you couldn't see him
when you were watching it on crt
television back when i was a kid there
wasn't enough resolution so a lot of the
stuff is lost
uh
uh when it went to tv
but this restored version you could see
it the way it was intended like it would
have been in the movie theater it looks
[ __ ] badass
those ships
i found out later on um that those ships
were made out of uh
brass or copper copper that's what it
was copper yeah they got melted down
somebody just pointed that out yeah they
were copper and they were beautiful
there are photographs that existed of
them they were polished copper
and they looked really good and had
lights in them and stuff and they were
they could move a little bit
and they were probably about i don't
know two feet maybe three feet across
what they look like
they were miniatures but they weren't
that small
and uh
you know they were
shooting them as they were kind of going
over
a model about the size of like a train
models you know those model trains it
was like that's what the terrain looked
like but they look good on film real
good
and um
but this copy you can kind of see the
damn force field the
force field beams i forgot what he
called them any gravity beams or force
beams
yeah something like that because like
legs he says they're like
electromagnetic legs yeah initially well
i think he says invisible legs i think
is what he says we'll see because they
were gonna do like the whole tripod
situation but either because of the
budget or because
uh just logistically it wasn't feasible
uh they decided that they were going to
kind of do it in post-production and
make it but in some of the scenes you
can see like a little sparky kind of
shapes of light with the right dots in
them like dots you know so it still had
a tripod look to it but you know they
you know they didn't have to build the
whole like big configuration right and
if it was going to be a tripod then the
thing would have ended up being a puppet
or a marionette and it probably wouldn't
have looked that good
yeah i mean i think they did the guy
that directed this byron haskin i mean
the producer george powell uh who was
responsible for producing a lot of like
really classic uh 50 sci-fi he picked
byron haskins specifically because he
was like a special effects guy
uh and he wanted kind of his expertise
on it because you have to think this is
1953. you know you'd had stuff like when
worlds collide and things like that but
in the 50s early 50s sci-fi was still
seen as like a kid's genre yeah and i
was watching something uh earlier about
this where somebody was saying and i
believe it was um ann robinson the woman
that played uh sylvia in the in the
movie
and she was saying uh when they first
brought this uh screenplay adaptation
even though obviously uh you know orson
welles had done the radio uh you know
play of it in 1938 which caused a big
hubbub
um but by the time the 50s rolled around
they had been wanting to do and add up
to another adaptation of it but a lot of
the producers were like man sci-fi
it's just kind of it was just like a
cheap kids genre like i said they just
wanted to make something for cheap that
like kids would go watch for a dime on
saturday morning or whatever they didn't
really see
i guess they didn't really see a lot of
like serious potential in it until later
on
but
i think this movie definitely did help
though because the cool thing about this
movie and this is comes from the book
too but i really like
how
well one thing that this movie did that
i think really hadn't been done that
much previously in sci-fi
is that it has you know the military in
it it has scientists in it but they're
portrayed more positively because i feel
like a lot of sci-fi movies in the 50s
either like the military and the
scientists were actively like working at
cross purposes or
you know there was a lot of conflict
between them and the public there was
other things like that but this one had
more of like a cooperative vibe to it
and in a way to me that made it scarier
because they're like look everybody's
working together like the scientists in
the military and the public everybody's
on board
and
and the uh and the aliens are still
kicking our ass like they're still
wiping out the whole entire world like
there's nothing we can do so i
that kind of like rule neck even though
you know spoiler everybody knows this
but uh you know the the aliens end up
dying the martians end up dying from
just uh microbes at the end that we are
immune to um you know that's the only
thing that saved our asses like we tried
to blow them up with an atom bomb and
nothing happened and you know what i
mean and like even in the movie they're
just like well we're hosed you know what
i mean well it's also globalist all the
nations of the earth are working
together yeah to try to fight these
things yeah but that's what would happen
yeah people would put aside differences
and try to figure out how to [ __ ]
because it's an invasive [ __ ] species
um
another thing i liked about it is that
in the original book
the martian main weapon was just what it
was called the heat ray which was an
invisible beam of heat that could leap
from one person to the next
and they would instantly burst into fire
and it could
and it would send a building just
immediately [ __ ] up in flames so so
he's talking about laser
yeah i don't think wells had any
knowledge of a laser were lasers even
theoretical
an invisible ray of heat and things
would immediately burst into maybe but i
gotta say like h.g wells was pretty on
the ball yeah uh like a lot of stuff
that he put into like you could really
finagle some of that into this look man
he predicted this on the other thing he
was pretty ahead of his time now they
rebooted it in this movie because an
invisible ray of heat wouldn't look too
impressive on on a [ __ ] movie yeah
because it's invisible so it's here a is
basically a giant [ __ ] shower of
sparks that come out of it [ __ ] much
cooler yeah it would just
reduce dudes into ashes you know whether
you were mexican or not
everything they could have they had the
two they had they had they had the damn
three stooges out there two white dudes
and a fat mexican dude guarding the damn
metal [ __ ] cylinder the alien craft
and he goes maybe they think we're
friendly yes we're friendly people
better than another with the [ __ ]
kids
they came up with a white flag yeah with
a white flag they were thinking they
would they were
we're gonna show them we're friendly
we're friendly well that was another
thing that i was gonna say that's cool
it's like at the beginning yeah like
when the aliens invade everybody's just
not like oh [ __ ] now we're done for
everybody's like cool aliens it's like
hey bud they're like trying to make
friends and the aliens like
not having it yet
i'm like oh [ __ ] they killed the three
stooges and then
like when the cops show up they find the
piles of ashes shaped like the dudes on
the ground i was like that's classic
they're [ __ ] smoking
yeah i had forgotten about because i
hadn't i had not seen this movie since i
was a little kid yeah so like seeing it
again i was like man that's pretty
[ __ ] up for 1953.
like it just turned him into like a
little yeah a little ash stain on the
ground i was like damn yeah and then uh
then they threw in a new uh thing that
the alien uh war machine they called the
war machines is what they call it
there's a good
album
uh by thin lizzy it's called war of the
worlds and it's narrated by [ __ ]
richard burton and a whole bunch of
other ones you guys want to listen to
that i had that album as a kid with a
double album it was really good
uh you can get it
on youtube
and they also did like a live tour with
thin lizzie and a bunch of people they
were narrating they do like a narration
of the whole story it's good
h.g wells wore the world's thin lizzy
um anyway uh
hg wells called called them war machines
and martian war machine well in this one
the martian war machine could also uh at
the tips of the little manta ray wings
there were these um green
clear kind of emitters and it would
throw out this damn green
i don't know what would you call it
little green droplets not droplets just
like a little
wave would come out in the movie didn't
they call it like the skeleton beam or
something like that no it was
uh was that something else there you
could see the skeleton
but uh the uh 50s jeff gold gold blue
gold blonde with gold blue that's his
name yeah he's going oh look at it it's
using uh what do you call it something
or other uh it's a meson
uh
causing the the forces that hold the
atoms together
uh to disintegrate so it's causing
matter to fall apart that was cool that
was a good time i bought it yeah
just you just hit the hit with the meson
beam and you just [ __ ] fall apart
because your atoms just dissipate
jane berry is that actor's name yeah uh
this was actually
maybe only his second movie i want to
say
initially i didn't know this i don't
even think this is on the wikipedia page
initially i think they wanted lee marvin
for that role oh that'd be good um but
then they decided they're like no we
kind of want some more like character
actors like some more people that are
like unknown because i mean even in 1953
like lee marvin was pretty famous so i
think they wanted you know so you could
get more of a kind of every jeff
goldblum [ __ ] role is this guy
well i kind of well the 50s scientists i
mean that's such a character trope i
mean they were in like pretty much all
of these i don't even know like where
the first iteration of that came from i
think that was just like an individual
he's just like a character like a stock
character uh in a lot of these kind of
movies although there were some 50s uh
social commentary that would be lost i
think on modern people they went out of
their way to let you know that this girl
was intelligent and that she wasn't
married that she was living on her own
they weren't married and they're
[Laughter]
they're running around together and
they're not married to each other yeah
which that was in the 50s that was like
futuristic concept hey i'm a doctor i'm
a scientist and you're an educated woman
and we're
dealing with this [ __ ] problem of
alien invasion and we're not married and
fallen and we're not married to each
other yeah they're in the aliens and
we're married
we're into each other because we like
each other the parent the family has
nothing to do with it
which that was like i said for 1953 was
probably yeah that was the news i don't
know like well that part of it um
well there was like in the
preacher who was her uncle said that's
okay i like that guy
yeah preacher was okay with it preacher
already gave the blessing before he even
knew what was up
yeah that was funny and they threw that
in there captain blairdo says i wondered
why the aliens had the tri-color eyes
then found out that color movie or t
color movies tv was seen as high-tech or
exotic yeah and actually i really liked
uh that kind of three because i love
that rgb kind of i love that kind of
look yeah when we were growing up
if you got real close to the television
the cathode ray tube it was three lines
over and over again a red green and blue
one over and over and over again and
when if you were a little kid you could
get and you could see them
remember them they were about a width of
a hair but you could see those
it was a little three bars over and over
again
i immediately knew it was talking about
because i was a little kid looking at
the television
and remember and then the scientist goes
it's a television it's an electric eye
like a television camera yeah yeah
i mean that was some deep [ __ ] when
you're back in the 50s yeah like a
television camera okay and it's color
it's got three
you know because they were used to black
and white yeah so it was color so that
was a big deal
it had a color tv
in its face in space the marshmallows
figured out
color television well they're clearly
way ahead of us
well they were they were
now uh i was gonna say that uh the
character that gene berry plays and
maybe other misti's will know this uh
his name is clayton forrester
and uh that's the evil scientist evil
mad scientist on mystery science theater
that's where they got the name room uh
it's homaging war of the worlds
so every time we were watching the movie
i was just like
clayton foster but yeah now people have
mentioned uh the the tom cruise wore the
worlds i'd say it was pretty good
it's okay i like it i didn't love it but
it was pretty good i thought it was good
there's only one thing wrong with it
that was uh
who did that that was uh old west's name
in it that was steven spielberg's huge
billboard didn't be over do that stephen
stephen spielberg okay this wasn't made
when steven spielberg was really at the
height of his game this is what was it
2005
i think it was mid 2000's
maybe late 90s i thought i thought i
think it's like i think it's 2005.
if i'm not mistaken directors have a
half-life all right they don't last
forever unless you're somebody like
[ __ ]
you know kubrick okay even he went uh
kubrick cooper went out strong he did
um but if you make a bunch of movies you
get too deep in the industry you start
to you start to age out and gets dumb
okay
um spielberg really could have had a
masterpiece ahead he not [ __ ] up the
story
the whole concept
that the aliens were underneath of the
ground and [ __ ] would come out of a
bolt of lightning it's just a stupid
idea don't love it stupid
because part of the what made war the
world's good one of the really good
parts of the [ __ ] story is people on
earth seeing the martians launch from
mars and seeing the damn cylinders
coming and yeah because that would be
really scary because then there's this
oh man
if they just pop out the ground
everybody's just like oh well there you
are yeah yeah there's no
there's no um you know there's no
waiting for it you know what i mean
there's no anticipation that it's coming
no suspense because in the book it was
it was like uh for for a lot for the
people that were in the know ogilvy was
an astronomer who was watching it was
trying to call everybody's attention to
it
but really only the
in the original story only the educated
people would listen to an astronomer
they knew it was coming but a lot of
other people didn't have any idea the
working people right because there
wasn't telecommunications in the 1800s
when this shit's happening
just a cylinder would land in the damn
park and you're like what the [ __ ] is
that
then the soldiers would show up and then
a couple days later the soldiers get
vaporized by a [ __ ]
walking tripod with a damn heat rain
it's catching people in a basket and
throwing them in the back and then later
you see this [ __ ] evil
octopus looking ding with a damn mouth
and evil eyes [ __ ] drawing blood out
of people and injecting it into its own
veins and yeah your mind's wigging out
and then all of a sudden it's spraying
off this damn [ __ ] red fluid
everywhere blood
and then you find out it's seeded the
ground with these damn seeds and the
martian red weeds taken over and it's
killing everything that they're
terraforming the [ __ ] earth to be
like mars with that right there man
that's wells [ __ ] thinking way ahead
terraforming
worship terraforming he thought that
[ __ ] he thought that [ __ ] out
they had a lot of earth they would want
mars
on earth
yeah so well obviously they're like we
want to make this conducive to our right
biology
which is what you would do yeah now that
was left out of um
that's what i was and that's another
thing i was going to bring up is that
all the stuff about the red weed and
about the martians essentially like they
were kind of like drinking people's
blood and they were actually using the
blood to water the red weed right weed
to [ __ ] get
martian
ecosystem going on earth
and it was growing everywhere it was
swallowing up all the damn buildings and
people were hiding from it and they
tried to get out the red weed had grown
up on everything and you had to fight
and get through the damn red weed and it
was destroying everything
and i'm not really sure why they left
that out of the 1953 version maybe they
thought it would be like too gruesome
too expensive maybe and 2x are too
expensive yeah um because it didn't need
to be in there i mean you know the it
because they changed the design of the
aliens they changed what the what the
ships looked like they changed all that
so spielberg did leave that in though
that i remember correctly they were
terraforming it if you correctly yeah or
they're not terraforming they call it
marsiforming
yeah it wouldn't be terrifying
because
yeah
martiford maniforming yeah it doesn't
sound really good does it um
yeah it was 2005 says louie uh
made around 600 million dollars at the
theaters yeah i thought it was uh made
of [ __ ] it's just the whole lightning
thing coming out of the ground concept
no that is a dumb idea it's like why
i just don't have waited so long i don't
yeah i don't understand like why that
had to because it just opens up this big
huge wait what that didn't need to be in
there right we've been mining for
thousands of years why haven't we found
a martial i mean right seeing why we
were making a salt mine
anything
if you wanted to
you know make it come from farther
because obviously we know that no
nothing lives on mars now or you know
nothing of that stature lives on mars i
mean they could have moved it to another
solar system and everybody would have
bought that but
making it so that oh they've been here
the whole time i'm just like yeah no
one's no one's buying that come on that
wouldn't happen you could still have
them from mars
that they were buried in if they could
be fair you could do that
surface for millions of years they'd be
buried that's believable right because
nobody's digging around you could go
yeah they were in suspended animation
underneath the surface of mars waiting
for a signal to [ __ ] from earth for
when time is right type of deal or
something like that or you could have
said
that no they're launching from mars but
they're not from mars they're using mars
as a as as a as a as a stationing area
because it's close because it's close
that they've stationed on mars and to to
to launch the assault from there that's
probably what yeah that's probably what
i would have done right out and you say
why not the moon the gravity is too low
and it's within reach of [ __ ] nuclear
weapons our nuclear weapons they're over
there it's too far away you could just
say that yeah i mean there's a lot of
other ways you could go about that than
having them buried in there i could talk
my way into it uh slasher fred said the
1950s had a lot of giant monster movies
like them or it came from beneath the
sea yeah they're all good and tarantula
uh tarantula had an uncredited
appearance by a very young clint
eastwood he also had an uncredited
appearance in revenge of the creature i
remember that i saw him uh in revenge of
the creature he was like a scientist
he was the main scientist with john agar
right and then like clint clintus played
his assistant so i remember he had to
like
handle a chimp at some point people
forget forbidden planet which that's a
good one too which as far as special
effects go will probably exceed this one
um
and without forbidden planet there would
have been no star trek star trek is
basically forbidden planet i mean
forbidden i don't think anyone's
forgotten it i think that's that one
this one
uh like again
you know there's there's a bunch of
other ones like that that are kind of
iconic you know what i mean forbidden
planet probably maybe even more than
this one although i don't really know
they're both pretty well regarded this
one in the blob
as far as sci-fi horror man is yeah
i love the blob it's a little bit goofy
but um but i'm kind of into it i think
that first half of the blob was [ __ ]
great i mean that that kind of alien is
like really scary to me and we keep
saying this we say this error i'm okay
i'm gonna write it down this time we
gotta do the 80s blob god yeah right
it's so good like one of the best 50s to
80s remakes so at 88 i think that was
because i mean you know but
i don't know what was i going to say i
was going to say something and then i
forgot totally what it was
um
but yeah it came from outer space was
based on idea by ray bradbury i read
yeah it's just kind of like
man obviously this is a story that uh
you know that resonated with a lot of
people because this you know obviously
you had the orson welles radio show
which was like a big thing and then this
was the first film adaptation
and then the one that came the steven
spielberg one that came out in 2005.
that was the fifth film adaptation so
there'd been like a bunch of other ones
in between there it's just such a
i mean you can take like all of the plot
points of the story i mean the 1953
version is
not
it's not a lot different than the book
the main protagonist is different
because i think in the book he's like a
writer
uh and then like his brother comes into
it later maybe his brother's a scientist
if i don't know it's been a while since
i read it
and uh i think in in the in the book i
think he's already married and he's
looking for his wife or something so
they did kind of they did kind of
incorporate that into the 1953 version
although they made it kind of more like
you know the scientist meets the girl
and then they you know fall in love over
the course of the alien invasion and
then he goes and like looks for her
afterward and it still has that
it's okay now here's another thing
that's interesting this has kind of a
little bit of a jesus c ending not
jesusy but like a kind of a religious
ending uh the book did kind of did
though too the weird thing about it
though is that h.g wells was not
particularly religious he was an
agnostic and actually went kind of
hardcore atheist later on yeah um but he
did put in the book that it was kind of
like
uh you know these small these small
things that god put upon the earth
and that was the only thing that saved
our asses because all of every all of
the people of earth like working
together all of our weaponry and stuff
like that didn't do jack against the
it's it's god in the grand architect
wave yeah that's kind of the way i just
generic god
like like the like the mason like like a
masonic god the grand architect is just
the god that really exists not the one
you not the one you think you know about
it's the one that is actual so it could
be like the force or
nature
yeah that's true you know the wisdom of
nature has done it because i feel like
selective breeding in nature and all
that the 1953 movie was slightly more
religious than the book was because i
think that even though h.g wells does
use that terminology when he's talking
about the microbes that wiped out the
martians
um
some like some of the uh there's one
character in there who's like a priest
or something like that who is a preacher
who is like um
not not a good character no well like
he's faith like he's very cowardly and
stuff whereas in the movie he's more of
like a pod he does get killed uh spoiler
alert but he's more of a positive
character and they all kind of like end
up at a church at the end and yeah it's
not the same character though no i know
not the same character no i know i
didn't say it was the same character i'm
just saying that it's that's i'm just
contrasting the way he the one from the
original story it's a [ __ ] priest
that have has lost his faith now that
he's seen that [ __ ] mankind is just
another animal and a [ __ ] another
animal from another planet is coming to
[ __ ] [ __ ] it up and that therefore
the god that he believed in was not the
real god because the god he believed in
would have not allowed that to happen
which is a pretty understandable uh
feeling to have in that situation
basically the pre the preacher realized
that humanity is just in the cosmic food
chain it's not under the protection of
any kind of god
that so it broke his mind and he was
doing evil things basically when he
tried to steal the steal a girl
what was it
or they tried to get he also tried to
reason with the aliens too and that that
he got killed
uh from from
if i remember correctly it's been a long
time since i've read the book and that
the way that character is handled in the
in the um
on the album
the thin lizzy album i think
i think he tries to go reason with the
aliens and they just [ __ ] fry them
well that kind of happens in the 50s
movie he's not necessarily trying to
reason with them
well i guess he kind of is i think he
tries to go a tone for his sins and try
to [ __ ] talk his way into it he was
insane he wasn't making any sense uh you
talking about the book preacher or the
book preacher i think he was he wasn't
making any sense he tried to reason with
him and atoned for his sins and
he tried to approach them as if they
were god and they [ __ ] killed him
well that's how i remembered it but like
it's been a long time since i've been in
the movie it seemed like he was
he approached the aliens in more kind of
like a spirit of friendship type of
deal i kind of feel like more oh in the
movie yeah in the movie that's what i
was talking about in the movie yeah he
tried to appeal to their humanity yeah
you know in the name of god and you know
god is going to preach it the martial's
like what the hell are you even talking
about we're not humans yeah
well
i think he knew he'd be killed
but he remember he said uh somebody has
to try to stop this conflict so he went
out there but he was he was annihilated
yeah it was just an impressive martians
didn't give two shits well they were a
predatory invasive species that had
already decided that we were we are not
supposed to be here you can't reason
with anything like that
yeah they really didn't care about and
they didn't decide they didn't even have
because like i said in the book they at
least had a reason for they were like
harvesting humans i think they even
enslaved some of them they were like
drinking their blood and stuff like as a
as a nutrient but in the movie they
didn't even have that justification so
they were just kind of like y'all are
just in the way
they're just like wiping everybody out
which like i said that's pretty scary
and that's like pretty heavy for like a
1950s
horror movie which they actually like
showed to kids later on yeah i thought
it was kind of well you know you have to
understand this is the world war ii
generation that's true they had seen
[ __ ] large-scale wars yeah
there was no negotiating in world war ii
that has all been decided you know
germany was waging war against russia
not to make get some kind of agreement
or to get russia to do anything it was
waging war against russia to depopulate
it
all right
a war of annihilation and it was kind of
the same way
in some in certain ways the united
states war against japan
they had they had taken positions on all
those islands
you couldn't take them prisoner if you
took them prisoner you'd have to take
them back to the ship they want any room
there
they could stop your whole military
invasion or your whole military
operation it wasn't really i guess it
was an invasion like a counter invasion
they could stop the whole military just
by surrendering to us because we would
couldn't put them anywhere yeah you had
to your army had to go back you know
so they fought over those islands and
killed everybody you know they took a
few prisoners on each island but
we're talking like four or five per
island you know you could take that many
guys onto a ship but you couldn't take
300 dudes onto a ship you did just kill
them out
so they were just wars of annihilation
you couldn't take prisoners
steven beat says hello guys i've just
found this channel so i'm a bit of a
virgin here lol hello welcome
hi there thanks for the welcome yeah
uh there's so much backstory i can't
explain it
[Laughter]
you'll figure it out
yeah how long have we been doing this
[ __ ] now actually i think this summer
it'll be six years we've been doing the
show yeah and uh we've just added more
and more content since then we have
there's so many like [ __ ] in jokes
and yeah i'm surprised you found so so
much backlog i figured we were shadow
band
no okay we thought we have new people
coming on all the time like i said it's
our our new subscriptions have never
it's always been
averaged the same like pretty much every
month
uh yeah murder hornet says uh wednesday
and friday shows are the best yeah
uh the martians were kind of space nazis
they yeah yeah
yeah i mean they they were just like
they weren't even they were didn't even
have like the tiny tiniest bit of
humanity like that they were nazis have
yeah they were just they did not give a
single [ __ ]
yeah
yeah they were just like stop it it was
like stomping on an ant hill they're
just like well we want your [ __ ] so bye
yeah
yeah they didn't care
but um
yeah i mean
what cheryl said that she had never seen
uh this version of war of the worlds
honestly
yeah i'm gonna say
now i think there's a there's one or two
that i haven't seen
maybe out of the five
but
i you know i the tom cruise version is
okay um i don't love it this one's got a
lot more so this one well this one is a
lot more stylish
i really like um you know i'm more of a
into like uh beautiful looking effects
practical effects yeah i love the
miniature work in this i love the bright
colors i love the technicolor i love the
design of the alien ships the edit on
this movie is tight as [ __ ]
it is it's not constant action it's not
a very long movie is it i think it's
like only what was it 83 minutes
something like that and they don't [ __ ]
around with dialogue or anything i mean
there is dialogue but it's just enough
to get to get the scene over with and on
to the next scene it's uh like a comic
book it's constantly moving forward well
they're like we got we got a lot of
ground to cover these martians are like
[ __ ] up the whole entire earth it's
almost like watching a propaganda film
like a war propaganda where there's
it's just one thing after another after
another after another after another have
you ever seen a war propaganda movie or
you know which is it's a movie about war
that's yeah and they you know hollywood
was good at that because they were
making those kind of movies for world
war ii
yeah yeah and a real propaganda war
movie
is
fast-paced
uh it's kind of like morality tales
but they're not lingering on anything
it's constantly moving forward they
don't really give you a whole lot of
time for introspection or anything or it
will do its own introspection for you
and then you learn that lesson let's go
on to the next one it's they're like
very instructional
it's like that
but it's good you'll see it it's like
watching a war movie
it's what it is
cheryl says in war of the worlds was a
radio show i heard people thought it was
real and freaked out some people did uh
that was in 1938 and that very famously
uh orson welles their radio production
of it and i think at the beginning they
did have a disclaimer that said hey this
is like the hg wells book or whatever
but then like the way that it was
presented was as if it was a series of
real news reports so it was almost kind
of like found footage
um
i think that some people did absolutely
think it was real but i think that in
later years that got overblown you know
what i'm saying i don't i don't think
there was a thing where people were like
oh god the martians are kind of like
jumping off buildings and stuff i'm
pretty sure that didn't happen
um i think that was like a later media
legend kind of urban legend type of
thing but some people did actually think
it was real i did see some stuff in
papers back then where some people did
think that where some people like called
to complain can we say too that one of
the narrators of this now some of the
narration is done by uh cedric hardwick
who i think did a bunch of other
cartoons and stuff but there was some
narration in here too by paul freeze
who i mean you know his voice he's the
honda mansion right at disney like the
ghost toast because as soon as i heard
him in there i'm like hey it's paul
freeze he did a bunch of like cartoons
and disney stuff and all that kind of
yeah very very uh distinctive voice if
you ask me this is the definitive movie
all right um of war the worlds this is
the one you want to see
um although i really enjoyed the the
album
it is cool i guess it's still on youtube
we watched it on youtube a few years
back i guess he's still on there the
thin lizzy album yeah it's narrated by
uh
uh richard burton when he's sober
well sounded sober is he ever sober
though no i don't know
he was he didn't he was never sober he
just had like shades of drunken yeah
and
he'll narrate in between songs and then
it'll go into a song that's kind of like
related to the [ __ ] war of the worlds
theme
and then then he'll narrate some more
and then there's more songs there's like
a musical version of it it's cool yeah i
liked it and they have a lot live stage
productions of it real [ __ ] with a
huge [ __ ] martian that's what we
watched that's what we saw on youtube
yeah you can see that too uh although
that's a little bit shorter than the
album as i remembered it i remember the
album was a little bit longer feeling
it's kind of the the show is kind of
like they condensed it a little bit
yeah yeah
captain bolero says someone shot a water
tower thinking it was a tripod machine
yeah i remember hearing something about
that
but like i said i'm sure if people did
it did happen but i don't think it was
as widespread as
i don't you know i don't think it was
like millions of people flipping out and
thinking like the martians were actually
coming or not uh stephen beat said i
think wells loved the idea his
production was mistaken for real and
built the myth up a bit he had a huge
ego
yeah i could see that too i could see
that too he seemed like an okay guy but
yeah
it's weird because now every time i
think of h.g wells
i all because i saw the movie time after
time so many times when i was a kid now
i always think of like malcolm mcdowell
yeah instead of like actual hg wells
like wow he seems like such a nice man
i'm like wait i'm taking a balcony
cheryl says she has
has the thin lizzie album on vinyl yeah
i had that as a kid i lost it though it
would open up it had a bunch of really
cool illustrations and paintings in it
and it had a little book inside and
[ __ ] it was this neat the book had a
whole bunch of pictures you should get
it again that'd be neat of course we
don't have anything to play it on yeah
we'd have to buy a record player yeah
although you know because of hipsters
you can buy uh
nice record players again now like if
anyone pulled up an image from that
yeah i remember us watching that on
youtube like a few years ago when it
began like the live the live stage one
with the with the big tripods and
everything it was like actually pretty
cool
but i don't
i can't really remember
i mean other than this one this is
really the most even though it's it
differs a lot from the original story in
the sense that it doesn't have the red
weed it doesn't have the blood drinking
it doesn't have some other things you
know it's not the cylinders and stuff
but
um
sorry foot that's what the album looked
like
it was very steampunk looking because it
was happening in the 1800s
yeah that's super cool yeah
i mean before yeah before anybody knew
what steampunk was yeah
it was all 18 18 yeah 1800 style
that's uh that's the martian war machine
fry in the front end of the thunderchild
which was a british iron clad that went
out there to go fight the martians to
get him out of london but now they just
[ __ ] fried that thing
oh you just reminded me too that this
movie actually had the prototype of the
flying wing in it yeah it does yeah
they actually used footage from from a
secret aircraft yeah that my dad said
that the only images he ever saw of it
back in the day yeah that was the only
time they would show it
because that's yeah that's what was
funny we were watching because like i
said i hadn't seen it since i was a kid
and i was just kind of like holy crap
they're putting the flying wing like
right up in there i said that was like
pretty that was secret back in 1952 yeah
wasn't it
pretty secret uh very well top
secret-ish secret-ish yeah
it was hard to see that
that was approved photos of it or
proof uh proof footage of it yeah
because there's totally footage of like
the real flying wing there
fourth drawer down says rumor has it
that richard burton had a gnt placed in
his hand at 4 p.m every day oh probably
true yeah
can i i can just imagine him sitting in
his study or whatever and then it's just
four o'clock the the clock strikes four
o'clock and his hand goes out like that
somebody just comes in yes
how cool would that be i think it'd be
cool if like if i did that and somebody
put like i don't know like a
mocha frappuccino with my hand at four
o'clock every day that'd be nice i don't
need a gnt but
the broadcast uh broke for commercials
you would think people would get a clue
yeah
see that's what i thought and i thought
that
if you had listened to it from the
beginning the orson welles what i'm
talking about if you listen to it from
the beginning that was very very clear
that it was
a a radio play
and you know and yeah like you pointed
out it's like it went to commercials you
would think that yeah i mean unless you
wanted to believe it maybe and well and
you know i hate to say but some people
that listen to it maybe were maybe they
weren't all that bright
you know that that could be too here's
some more illustrations from inside the
album
oh yeah see that's cool yeah from inside
the album there's a lot of stuff like
that that lady's like [ __ ] this yeah
they're all
everybody's falling over each other and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh this was from the inside this one of
the dudes is fantasizing about
rebuilding victoria and london
underneath the ground safe from the
martians and that that's from the inside
of the album
that's like that's like the city
that's pretty cool yeah
that's pretty cool yeah
they had a real good [ __ ] drawing oh
yeah
see oh [ __ ] drawings of the red weed
red weed taking off [ __ ] don't smoke the
red wheat don't smoke that rabbit
man i lost it you [ __ ] it up here it
goes you [ __ ] it up
red weed taking over everything yep yep
yeah camp guys said they only announced
the orson welles disclaimer one time at
the very start of the broadcast yeah
that's what i thought the entire episode
only lasted about 30 minutes okay see
for some reason i thought it was an hour
but i guess not okay
so if it only took place over 30 minutes
and there was only a thing at the
beginning then yeah if you just tuned in
like
two or three minutes in and didn't hear
that
then
okay
i'll allow it
i was just reminded i think somebody
brought this up on one of my other on
one of the other shows but
they did a similar thing in the uk in
the 90s with that with that thing ghost
watch
that made it look like a real call-in
show that they were investigating like a
poltergeist like for halloween
and they had like all these real
uh
news presenters and stuff that everybody
in the country recognized
and they all went along with this lark
and they made it seem like
hey we're just for halloween we're doing
a fun thing we're going to this house
that says it's haunted it has a
poltergeist in it and then like it gets
scarier and scarier like [ __ ] really
starts to happen
and a lot of people in the uk thought
that was real too
but i've seen it and
i was like i could see how you could
fall for i mean you know nobody nowadays
would but back in the 90s if you didn't
see the very beginning yeah you had to
yeah you could totally fall for that
uh
where are the worlds brought to you by
pepto-bismol
and gaines burgers or what the [ __ ] ever
uh mr 88 says all of the commercials in
the world of the world's radio broadcast
are fake but presented within the
broadcast as real
oh interesting see i didn't know that
that's one of the reasons people took it
as authentic like i said very very like
very early found footage i like it i
like it trying to get like the bearish
millitude in there all right so maybe
people weren't as stupid as i was
thinking so they did actually try to
make it seem like it was real
yeah they're saying that they're they're
reminding me that
all those songs from that album are on
youtube yeah the whole album is on
youtube yeah yeah it's in a whole
playlist you can listen to the whole
thing at least it used to be maybe
they've taken it down yeah i mean that's
a while back that we listen to that but
um i think um the live version because
there's a lot there was a live show uh
that they did
for that
for that album um
and it's like you know only a couple
years back that they did i think the
whole live show was up there you can
watch it for free yeah it's cool like
really cool with special effects you
have a real [ __ ] martian war machine
come out it's pretty big they should do
more [ __ ] like that i kind of feel like
take like some cool like sci-fi or
horror classics and do like a big
musical musical version stage adaptation
of it with like [ __ ] cool ass special
effects and everything that'd be rad i'd
go see that
listening to the uh
to the radio version yeah but then
there's songs
they're pretty good they're pretty good
the only wayne i think is dude from then
lizzy did it yeah yeah the only time i
ever got to do that was once i went and
saw
i actually did get to go see like a
stage adaptation of dracula one time but
that was it wasn't musical though
although how cool would that have
been i wish i would have seen the one
that edward gorey did the
did all the uh stage production on that
have been really cool where he painted
all the backdrops and whatnot
okay so is that it for war of the worlds
i think so yeah and we'll go ahead and
shut it down yeah i mean [ __ ] if you
haven't seen war of the worlds like i
said amazon prime uh classic 50s sci-fi
yeah kind of feel like it's if you're
into sci-fi or horror you kind of need
to see this movie you haven't seen that
one and you're wrong and if you haven't
if you haven't seen the new touched-up
version of it that's for uh
it's on a free instant watch on amazon
prime it's it's a great watch yeah it
looks like it looks great it looks like
it's been restored well i think i
believe that this movie has a criterion
collection uh so it's been completely
like remastered and i'm assuming that
that's the version that you're watching
yeah i mean it's a lot better than what
the way it looked when i saw it on tv as
a kid yeah it looks really nice like the
colors are beautiful yeah and the aspect
ratio and everything yeah it looks right
as it was intended to see in the theater
when it was when it was new like off of
a really good copy and everything it
looks good see that's what i was saying
that's one of the best things about
being alive at this time yeah is that
you can see movies from [ __ ] back in
like the 1920s or from up to present day
the way they were intended to be seen
for a long time in the 80s you couldn't
you could just see it on tv or video and
it looked kind of shitty and vhs was
nowhere near as good yeah old television
i'm like if you saw it in the theater
then yeah it looked cool but if you saw
it at home it looked kind of like crap
yeah i had no idea like i said a couple
days ago i had no idea that enemy mine
was it was an expensive movie yeah it
looks great yeah because when you just
see it on like a jacked up tv or vhs
it's just kind of everything looks cheap
and crappy yeah and just like people
will talk about how shitty
[ __ ] conan looks and i was like dude
what copy are you looking at you see the
copy they're looking like you know
you're watching the free version on
youtube
conan did look [ __ ] up on vhs okay
because it just didn't translate you see
that see the way it was intended to be
seen theatrically
in hd
in that aspect ratio with the epic
[ __ ] uh soundtrack it's like watching
an opera it's [ __ ] looks great
you know and and and the costumes that
would look cheesy on vhs look great in
hd
the way they were intended to be seen on
the theater well yeah because that's
when you make a movie you're intending
for it to be seen in a certain
presentation at a certain aspect ratio
right certain color quality and it's
like if you've seen a vhs copy or a
low-res copy of [ __ ]
dino de laurentiis flash gordon it looks
[ __ ] crazy it looks stupid now you
see in hd the way it was intended to be
seen it looks [ __ ] great cause those
costumes are super expensive
yeah they don't really nice and you
don't really see the way they really
looked until you see it in hd
and the new touched up versions of
[ __ ] flash gordon talk about it has a
trip but see that's what i that's what i
like is that even i mean even like
shitty forgotten slashers from like the
1980s are getting loving restorations
because there's an audience out there
for them everybody wants to see the [ __ ]
as you know as good as possible totally
changes totally it changes the the
impression that the movie gives you oh
yeah big time yeah
um yeah okay so yeah yeah that's uh
that's it we went on for almost an hour
holy crap
uh but yeah so war of the worlds you
guys uh go watch it i think tomorrow
we'll probably be talking about
bullet yeah the steve mcqueen saw a
bullet last night because we watched
that last night so we'll probably talk
about that tomorrow you guys want to be
in on it tomorrow [ __ ] watch bullet
tonight steve mcqueen real good movie
great great that's on amazon prime two
but we had to pay 399.99 so it wasn't
free yeah that was like the beginning of
these movies kind of like you know heat
or [ __ ] ronin and uh a lot of blade
runner and uh mad max
yeah it was like it was like a noir yeah
movie really which i didn't realize
because i hadn't seen it since i was a
teenager probably and i had forgotten
that whole like noir aspect to it
detective movie
had a similar kind of ending as blade
runner
the original theatrical blade runner
kind of ending and it had a real good
chase scenes with the way they were shot
was kind of like you could tell that
inspired
mad max
looks good that car chase pretty much
inspired every subsequent car chase yeah
that's scarce i mean not much of an
exaggeration for how [ __ ] car chases
should happen in a movie
yeah and the opening title credits
[ __ ] i never seen anything like that
from the 60s man that looked like
something from the 90s yeah looked great
i love the score as well yeah but yeah
we'll talk about that uh tomorrow right
so yeah drop on by 3 p.m eastern
standard time tomorrow and we'll do a
live stream about bullet thanks for
dropping by everybody we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bye